what is the spine of a story I use the
term uh spine to describe what is
actually the central conflict of the
story I kind of stole the word spine
from William Goldman who uses it a bit
in his books uh his books are more um
story you know just telling stories
about the business but he does use the
term spine I use it uh because I liked
it and it accurately describes what the
spine is because it's just like in an
animal spine is a vertebrae and the
animal can't move and function without
it and that's the same function it has
in a story everything emanates from the
spine of the story but the spine the
more accurate term is the central
conflict it is the this the conflict
which must be resolved before this story
is over and likewise the second it is
resolved the story is over um and it's
absolutely essential essential that the
screenwriter know what the spine of the
story is before he or she begins writing
um even before you begin structuring uh
the story in its three acts and so on uh
you can't do that unless you know what
the story is about it's about this
central conflict I used to use when I
was teaching as an example Lawrence of
Arabia which is four hours long one of
the great films ever made four hours
long but the spine is uh a young British
officer in World War I goes to Arabia
and tries to become a god
that's it that's the spine one sentence
you should be able to say your spine in
one sentence this is the central
conflict and that this story cannot be
resolved until that is resolved what
happens to a guy who tries to become a
God uh and when it is resolved the story
is over and the screenwriters wisely
stopped the story at that point even
though TE Lawrence went on and had
another interesting life separate from
that uh this is the story they chose to
tell um when Lawrence Olivier uh um shot
hamlet in 1948 as a film that he
directed and started uh he started by
saying you see a tableau of characters
on top of the castle Elenor at night and
Olivier's voice over says this is the
story of a man who could not make up his
mind boom now that's Hamlet now if you
can boil Hamlet down to a sentence you
can absolutely do it with your story and
you have to do it what is the central
conflict of the story what is it about
and if you can't say it in one sentence
it's already wrong it means you're going
to what you're going to wind up doing
when you try to structure it is you're
going to go off writing yourself into
Corners following trails that lead
nowhere and then having to undo it throw
out those oh that's three weeks of work
down the drain let's go back and try
again and then eventually if you hanging
there long enough maybe you'll find the
spine that's a very sloppy and
ineffective way to go about
screenwriting you want to Fig figure
that out uh earlier in the process so
that your story is structured to tell
that spine That central conflict uh
every scene in the story every line in
the story every shot in the story in a
properly structured screenplay is
telling that central conflict not always
directly sometimes tangentially in
Lawrence of Arabia obviously not every
single sentence is is directly about
that but they're all about that moving
that central conflict forward uh and
that's how the screenwriters know with
this wealth of material what is it we're
we're going to shrink it down to the
stuff that tells That central conflict
if I'm understanding correctly then it
sounds like when we talked about earlier
in the video interview uh rules and by
this page this has to happen and you
were saying that some of that is just
Hoy or whatever but it sounds like with
the the party pitch or the spine that
that's something people need to know oh
absolutely right off the bat almost well
here's might the distin in my process
and again I call it organic
screenwriting is that once you have that
spark that her moment that thing that
seems exciting don't go don't try and
jump to a spine don't try and jump to
structuring your story that's what the
screenwriting books will tell you okay
now take this template we created for
you and we're going to start filling it
in no the next step in that process is
to start imagining anything take that
follow that through wherever it might go
if you have an here's a funny scene
write it down here's a character write
it down here's a snippet of dialogue
write it down just keep writing down
anything that comes to you and following
those roads and what will happen What
happens in my head and I think it
probably is true of most professional
writers what happens is out of
that free associating U process of
thinking of stuff that of where this
story might go you'll start to feel the
spine
coales uh beats will start start to
connect up and somebody used this uh
analogy I thought it was a good
one um you're looking for stuff that uh
beats little stuff you've thought of
that connects with the conjunctions so
and but but not the conne the
conjunction and so and but mean it's
causality this happened so this happened
this happened but this happened but is a
plot twist so is probably not but
they're connected or tole called it
causality there the one thing one scene
drives into the next scene if you're
just connecting it with the word and
that could be anything right you can
connect any two things with the word and
so that's probably not as helpful to you
anyway you start to feel this spine
start to visualize to you and it
becomes clear that this is where your
excitement lies this is the direction
literally like a spine it's like this is
the Direction the Story seems to want to
take it's organic it's where you're
interest interest lies where your where
your interest takes you and therefore
it's probably where the audience will be
most interested and
then uh that's not the end of the
process but that is where you start to
see it and now you start to refine that
into a spine I literally uh one sentence
that that you are comfortable with
saying this is the story I wish to tell
this is the conflict I'm going to and
then you do write that down you write
that down stick it on your computer
because you you ever want to get away
from that spine you got to stay on it or
the audience will start to fidget and
squirm and on top of that your writing
process will be miserable because if you
get away from your spine you're going to
write a bunch of scenes that you never
going to use um and that's that's the
that's the steps uh that I use and I
advise other people to do it again as a
working writer I can't afford to spend
months writing pages that are never
going to be seen by anybody body so and
it's not useful anyway there's no reason
for it so yeah the finding the spine
identifying the spine writing down the
spine especially with a screenplay uh is
absolutely critical as a writer for hire
do you always find that spark is that
ember always there weirdly yes uh
because uh even when I'm writing
something that's um as I often do a
children's story uh I go back to my
childhood I go back to my children's
childhoods and I find something that
triggers a memory that's in that's
worthy of the of the audience's time
spent following this little conflict now
with a children's show it's often 11
minutes sometimes 22 minutes uh so it
doesn't need to be as big as uh Lawrence
of Arabia but uh it's still something
that has some resonance some power uh we
had a conversation the show I I consult
on at Disney um a children's show and
somebody was writing a story where one
of the characters
um lost their favorite toy and we had a
conversation was that enough to hold up
an 11 minute story you lose your
favorite toy and then we all thought
about it together said you know what
when you're a kid you're 5 years old you
lost your favorite toy that's life and
death man that is absolutely a powerful
enough uh thing to hold up a story for
at least for 11 minutes and uh and we
could all identify with it and remember
that and and feel passionate about it
now it isn't always something that's
important sometimes it's uh just
something kind of silly and sometimes if
it's if the show and sometimes I do
write shows that are just kind of goofy
then I'm looking for a different kind of
inspiration it may not be dramatic in in
the tragic in that sense it was maybe
just more Goofy and funny and weird but
that too is a form of inspiration but I
I don't have any problem doing it um I
can't think of any shows that I've ever
written on where I felt absolutely
nothing when I was writing it I think if
I had ever experienced that I would have
just quit I would have said okay I'm not
doing this you can always find something
that's kind of fun and Goofy and
inspirational exciting uh about a given
story and uh that's that's the task
that's part of the job and I I I enjoy
that part of the job what if a writer
cannot boil their story down to one
sentence my advice is and I have given
this advice to many of my uh students
and private clients stop stop right
there uh if you can't do it it means
you're not focused on you haven't
identified the central conflict uh
that's why I like using spine or central
conflict as opposed to say log line or
premise which are the probably more
common terms but when you say log line
or premise that's conjures up more of an
image of of you're trying to boil down
the plot I don't care about the plot yet
the plot is not what's important app
plot is merely a device that we use to
tell the story the story being the
emotional through line of the story
that's the part that the audience
engages with well if you can't do it
then the audience is probably not going
to get engaged either there's no reason
to expect them to and the reason why
people have trouble boiling it down is
because of that because they're trying
to put the plot in the in the one
sentence doesn't matter what the plot is
uh it it's it's what is the
emotional conflict the through line
that's going to hold up this story uh
one of my favorite movies of the past 20
years 15 whatever it's been is Michael
Clayton which is a beautifully written
screenplay by Tony Gilroy and Michael
Clayton goes through all kinds of things
I mean there's he's in debt to the Mob
and his he's a bad marriage and his
brother hates him and he's uh he's a
compulsive Gambler just one thing after
another but the that's not the spine of
the story that's not the central
conflict of the story the central
conflict of the story is some version of
this uh Michael Clayton is this a sleazy
attorney corporate attorney who has to
disco has to decide how immoral is he
willing to be when he has a client who
starts killing people that's the central
conflict and this the central conflict
has ended at the climax of the story
when he's confronted the uh the
villainous
uh executive and she recorded her
confession ing to the murder in
accidentally unwittingly rather and he's
recorded it for the cops which means
he's going to lose a lot of money and
probably be in trouble with a lot of
people but he's done it because he
that's as far as he'll go he that's
that's where he drew the line and the
car one of the the big corporate person
says who are you and he says I'm Shiva
the god of death which is a call back to
an earlier line but it just means that's
it that's where I draw the line story's
over and the movie ends within 20
seconds of that 30 seconds of that the
conflict is over you never do figure out
the you know the rest of his problems
are still there but it doesn't matter
the central conflict has been resolved
so if you're having trouble boiling it
down to one sentence it's usually
because you haven't figured out what the
central conflict is what is the
emotional through line of this story
you're trying to put plot in there which
is not
relevant